here it comes here it comes San Diego
baby remember my friend Steven what's up
yeah dude we record all these memories
and watch them every day yeah
freaking cool yo man we got the beach
SeaWorld California burritos ah best
weekend with my best friend man Airbnb
really came through gonna be a good
winter
this place was perfectly at home baby
check this out oh we got already stocked
the best weekend can't get over how nice
this place is how are hey hey check this
out the TV's just playing Mario Kart so
it's not connected to a console I
checked I mean it's probably like
bluetooth or whatever you know this is
weird right Oh Steve are you hearing
that hello
I'm telling you there's some weird stuff
that's going on right now Zak did you
set this up
no is this you Steve oh who set this up
whatever man let's just have a great San
Diego yo Steven get over here Zak and I
are on fire Oh we're hitting a world
record you're getting everything on this
couch
that's just like exploding what was that
did you hear that it says this house
used to be a frat house what uh it got
shut down for partying too hard get a
late-night snack oh what's this
all right Zach good one you got me what
are you doing return I'm good yo you
excited - hi khlo Hoya tomorrow
sounds like a sausage fest dude I'm not
going unless they're chicks
I'm telling you Justin's been acting
weird I set up this cameras he does
anything weird tonight look at the
camera no what is that what is that
hey what were you doing last night I
don't know what you're talking about bro
no you do I saw you on camera you
filming me play their choice take me
John
listen Justin's my best friend okay well
he's - he's my best friend
but before that I was a bro he was the
one that helped me stop being a pro now
it's time to help him hey what's up bro
I got the new GTA 5 and say Family Guy
DVR'd if you just want to kick it fam we
need to break the bro code if we break
the bro code the demons will come out
give me the keys Ella oh no money to go
to Coachella D we're not crossing it
medium a backer of the play you need to
tell moms I'm open house gives you
powerful I don't know if you know but I
sitting here and the word they use for
bro is for darkness they're number one
girl
you're another one
you can see that's not my bro in there
a broman relieves a bro behind
breaking are rolled up breaking our Road
like breaking are rolled up breaking our
wolf at night it's just so sad what's
happening over there
oh yeah you don't know the half